c'est qu'on a un gros sous que vous ayez
eue par un truc qui vous est arrivé à
laquelle vous avez jamais une honte de
ouf car au mois fêtait j'avais j'avais
sortait des toilettes et j'avais pris ma
jupe non dans le lot ah ouais j'ai fait
comme ça des mètres et des mètres et des
vents très choyé tout le monde me
regardait j'étais à s'effacer dans un
premier temps donc une journée et en
fait c'était la honte absolue mais ce
que les gens n'osaient pas me dire va t
on voit ton cul à la valeur le nom de
restaurant t on peut vous le dire voilà
gentiment aux calmants madame vous avez
vous trouvé oui oui moi j'étais dans le
train un jour cette lettre avec les
toilettes automatiques qui ferment tout
seul ouais sauf que là ça marchait mal
et tous les gens qui faisait la queue
juste en train de faire pipi et la porte
s'est ouverte et là il y avait la moitié
du trajet qui faisait la queue on voit
les parties b on va les faire publier
mais j'étais jeune j'avais quatorze 14
et c'est là que je me rappelle et c'est
là que la porte est ouverte et avec m
jean kiffer belle
bozouls et quoi céder vomi au melon quoi
un moment j'avais donc à l'histoire
démarre bien j'adore le melon est bas et
que je mangeais du melon ça partait en
jet continu et un jour au restaurant
avec quelqu'un que j'avais invité j'ai
mangé un melon en entrée et cinq minutes
après deux manières irrépressible ces
partis en jet continu droit sur la
pauvre personnage alors yahia le nouveau
patron de ses huit qui m'envoient sms
je suis hyper jaloux tu n'as qu'a
regrettée haras je suis furieux
désespéré voilà froch je t'aime mon
chéri prend capitaux voilà revenu de
loin
vous avez bien lu une grosse monde à
part au quotidien
l'histoire que caroline en montant les
marches les marches du palais au
festival de cannes
oui d'accord la jupe s'est trouvé coincé
dans la ceinture mais vraiment dans tout
le tout les fesses toutes été découvert
ouais et c'était pas le jour où j'avais
des dessous les plus affriolants
d'habitude services n'avaient pas eu le
temps tel ou tel mais changez donc
j'avais une espèce depuis longtemps il
ya quelqu'un qui est dit le cul n'est
pas trop moche mais alors la culotte de
grand une horreur le cul des pas trop
moche c'est ce qu'on retient non c'était
mais c'était il ya quinze ans il est où
la loi de la gravitation fait que ça va
vers le bas si ça va